[Music]
so the only person that i've seen people
that i've well person because
the only person that i've seen in the
entire joe rogan comedy clique who's
actually been honest about brendan
schaub
has been
ari shafir
and to some extent
joey diaz a little bit correct he was
letting he was he was letting the veil
slip a little but he was still running
you know
yeah
some people failed him
you know no i mean true no no i mean in
a good way if i was like his friend i'd
be like i don't know i don't know if
this is that ready yeah that's all i
wasn't ready special to you you know
what i mean like i know yeah if that
ever happened to me i would be mortified
and i'd be like why didn't anyone see
why did somebody why did they set me up
for this video yeah exactly and not to
be not to dig on by like brendan schaub
that's always been the critique on him
when he did that hour you don't have
real friends is the critique
horey's a [ __ ] people like i like art
i've always liked artists amazing
amazing racist i mean let's start with
that you know i like ari because he
just leans into being a garbage person
as long as it's funny remember the kobe
thing that everyone was he made that
joke about kobe after the helicopter
ground got wiped off the planet for that
yeah oh they would have told you i've
heard that multiple times by the way
multiple times and i think you either
overruled them or didn't ask them or
they couldn't because
i'm a [ __ ]
thank you ari exactly and i will say
it's it's the last one they're afraid to
tell you because you're somebody's
friend
now i don't know he's gonna say that but
we know the reason
the funny thing is without one of the
other things is
so it aired and then they tried to take
it down off the internet right and the
internet reacts to that in an angry
manner the internet has an orgasm says
you cannot delete our food and so then
it got pushed way higher if they didn't
try to scrub it it would have been like
no i didn't see it that's why
yeah um
that's true it's it's the same way we
talk about like the rock getting mad at
the gay rock song that's that some black
guy did right where it's like if you
would have said nothing that video would
have come and gone people would have
laughed it's a funny video what do you
think a minute you said you showed it
bothered you now it's all it is now
why you can't scrub the cell meme it's
gotta stay up okay
we'll find it yeah there are no quilts
of him
i wonder how long that takes that one
takes to shake
like that that would that would hurt i
think when you're parachuting in
deadpool 2
i think you're like i think yeah that's
true right
we talk about reddit and that stuff in
the hospital the filter prompts you
mine's different
i know i [ __ ] frown
that stuff hurts my feeling that's why
i'm not in social media it's not because
i think i'm better than anybody or
anything like that you do think you're
better than people brandon and other
than the face builder but every time i
hear this clip it's like you do though
you do and ari's one of the few people
that will still go back on rogan
after saying that because friends for a
long time and already should first like
can you say what you want about martial
island and he's funny yeah he's archer's
a funny guy but he's an island man he
doesn't need anybody else he doesn't
give a [ __ ] he has a flip phone he won't
buy a smartphone like he's [ __ ] weird
that's how he is you know
um
but yeah i mean
everyone's cut they did their little
thing you know they they went uh they
went on their little tour of the podcast
to this day at least unless there's new
information and frozen said there's
nothing new the the tiger belly crew
still hasn't seen brendan's evidence
nope you know and it's kind of just been
you know
so
stupid filter cracks me the [ __ ] up man
yeah but when they said try to take it
down what were they talking about he
didn't try to take down a special did he
no he couldn't have this i would have
known
oh no it's there and yeah by the way
yeah five times
five times i i watched the base
frequency
uh reviewed the gringo poppy thing and
remember we were talking about it he did
confirm it on his documentary thing that
it was
five different recordings and if you
re-watch it you could see the people in
the front row keep changing
to different people he wore the same
shirt right yeah and uh beijing did
point something out that was a really
good point was like the problem is
why did they light up the audience so
much you know
um so yeah if that that that 20
how long's the special
the 25 minute special okay
that 25 minute special
was five takes so what you're looking at
is
the the creme de la creme
of that entire stand that was several
nights
that was several nights of recording and
they got 25 minutes of garbage out of it
yeah but you have gems like this walked
in i go mama mama you know i love mama
what are you doing i know you know i'm
on keto i know i know you know somebody
told you i'm on keto she goes miho miho
bueno handler meal meal
sorry
is your mother-in-law speedy gonzales
on delay on delay
meet me
who's your uncle who's her who's who's
who's her brother slowpoke rodriguez and
then like yo so check it out right like
so i said i'm on keto
so she goes oh me ho come here right and
she leads me in the house but then i
just walked into a tunnel that was
painted on a
wall oh that's the road runner
it doesn't matter it's all the [ __ ]
cartoon honestly
that's what they say
they don't take habron over i know i
know a lot of mexican people no they'll
say cabron once yeah they won't go wrong
you'd be like are you okay
are you all right i can't stop saying
i'm wrong i can't stop
she grabs this straight she goes cabron
cabron look
she didn't say it frozen what were like
we're at seven cabrons right
around cheetos
it's kino [ __ ]
oh
it's keto
i hate brendan shop yeah most people do
most people do how's the how's the video
doing how's the special doing so glad we
have the plug-in because we can actually
see that it has a now oh god it's 161
000 down votes now but at least it got
more up votes no 38 000. oh it's it's
right around there
not great 5 300
comments let's go 1.1 ah
he kicked a lower than 1.1 on imdb
person at this point what are you going
to give him
[Music]
[Applause]
and
it was worth it
because of jokes like this
walk in the house these mexicans give a
[ __ ] about social distancing there was a
mask in sight i walk in the house
there's a mariachi band
in the house they're being they share
this pinata there's flaming hot cheetos
spraying over the goddamn living room
i can i royce man man please
i highly doubt any of those things were
happening no i don't think so either and
also
i mean i'm not going to [ __ ] about
you know whatever but isn't it just
these are just really tired racial
stereotypes
again like that's not even funny like
racial stereotypes are hacky but they
can be funny you're good at them yeah
but he's just
just jamming as many stereotypes as he
can come on cabron
pinata
he's at a cartoon mexican house like i
don't know how else to explain it
also when i think of mexican food i
think hot cheetos he's you're right and
also he's talking you know what he's
talking like the mexican bullet and
roger rabbit
that's right
that's the one bullet yeah the mexican
wood
i walked in i like my girl jesus christ
quite the party
that was your
line
quite the party quite the party
okay can we can we try to help him
what's the better punchline i mean the
setup was terrible but what would be the
punchline that you would do here a bunch
of mexicans in your house they're making
a mess they're hitting pinatas or being
cartoon mexicans you walk in what's the
first thing you say
um
is this a quinceanera or a car show
i like that i like it i mean i was just
why are there like 60 mexicans in here
there's only one toyota trucelle parked
outside
who left their lawnmower in the living
room
having to walk over piles of bud light
with clamato to get in the house
there you go brendan
what are we celebrating once you get
into harvard early what's going on here
what's in the garage at taco truck
first off she wouldn't get into harvard
brendan she would get into brown
you'd be the best you get to go for it
and besides she's [ __ ] mexican she's
going to cosmetology school
absolutely she is oh
[ __ ]
i got my cosplay called i got my
cosmetology degree yeah what did you
have to do to get in open the door like
i mean come on there's a there's not a
big barrier to be able to do that [ __ ]
nope just turned 15 and went [ __ ] yeah
that makes sense
the other thing i love about the mexican
culture is you guys stick together you
guys are so loyal to each other you
[ __ ] have each other's back and i
love that white people we're not like
that are we
huh
he'll go there
he'll go where mercer is afraid to go
he'll go where anybody went back in
2005.
okay you know what i'm done watching
this joe rogan cover band i i can't okay
i can't because i don't even like the
original band stand up that much anyway
good luck brendan yeah good luck in your
comedy thing
calming is what he calls it he's calm
calmly
thank you